we went to Paramount to pitch two films
the day we pitched Bad Grandpa we
pitched a movie where Willie Nelson was
going to play this ass kicking karate
guys you get to see Willie Nelson kick
ass Jeff and I are like we hope they
don't pick Bad Grandpa because that's
going to be a nightmare to pull off
the whole movie's predicated on people
reacting that's the last thing we wanted
and we went in there and pitched and
then they said we want to do Bad Grandpa
we look like we've been punched in the
stomach someone just bought a movie from
us and we were so bummed I was just like
telling myself oh it's going to suck
this get the makeup done for 3 and 1
half hours every day but after the very
first prank we did it went good and all
that stress went away and I felt like I
think we got this i got this I'm so
happy we did it now